[Music]  another man is dead people make choices  Wendy when I live on the weight of those  decisions at least it meant it was good  for us we know the Murray birth wonders  millions of dollars a year for the  Navarro cartel what we need to know are  the details of how he does it  you do realize that you're betting  everything I'm being able to pull this  off came as some surprise spoken to  you're a businessman oh you died  martín use you up and spit you in may I  remind you of your debt to us  don't [ __ ] with my client I'll kill your  children look me in the eye and tell me  that you've never lied to us about  anything  have you killed other people or not kill  pk  guys that's it please to school learning  well know these people that we work for  thinking we look different than them  and you're the one who is always said  people make choices  [Music]  [Music]  you